everyone this is Steve Weintraub and I
am with Chris Morgan here who you might
know from such movies as fast in the
Furious four five six seven basically
all of them from Tokyo Drift yeah even
from Tokyo Drift so let's just jump on
in first of all on camera I had a blast
with Hobbs and Shah so congratulations
on the film thank you and we're out
that's the entire site so before we get
into the actual movie I want to ask you
what we call some random fun questions
excellent right uh what what TV show
would you love to guest right
Oh God one that is active on the air
right now sure let's go with that mm
well Game of Thrones is over would have
loved it loved it yeah I mean I'm gonna
go back in the way back Time Machine
1818 come on so good Magnum Magnum right
now those kind I could see where that
fits in your mentality kind of precise
it's what I was raised on sure you know
it's those types of movies I noticed you
had a poster right outside like right
outside this room there is jaws Temple
of Doom you walk in you're like oh yeah
this is like that's my vibe that's when
you are getting ready to work on a new
fast movie or spin-off I do you sit down
and like rewatch any movies to let get
you in the mood or is it sort of like
you now have this stuff down where
you're like I got it both I think we've
talked about this before but I used to
work in a video store for a lot of years
a lot of years so I've seen a lot of
films and and kind of have that as a
foundation but I'm always watching
things and when I'm writing something I
tend to watch things that are
inspirational or you know will have a
little bit of that similar vibe so Hobbs
a shot you know you hit kind of lethal
weapon tango and cash
butch and Sunday and it's like those
types of films I'll take a look at just
because you want that you know to just
that inspiring sort of feel or flavor
but yeah yeah I'll watch a lot of stuff
what movie have you seen the most in
your life hands down by far Raiders
Lost Ark by far I saw that I think 30
times in the theater when I was a kid
30 times that's a lot yeah that's also
in yeah that especially in the 1984 sure
and they would do a double feature back
then going back in that in the back in
the old time they would do a double
feature and so I would sit through I
think it was Raiders and Annie I'd sit
through both so I can see Raiders a
second time I think what's the other one
that was attached to it oh I can't
remember but either way I think it was
trauma later but yeah I would sit
through whatever the double feature is
so I can watch the movie twice don't do
that these days nowadays you go see you
pay your ticket you get cleaned out and
but I remember I watched Raiders first
time that I saw it my folks took me down
to the Grauman's Chinese ball what was
then the Grauman's Chinese Theater and
watched it they came in clean the
theater we just kept our seats and
watched the second time like that
hands down had the biggest effect of me
on from any movie ever for sure
um yeah I I have nothing but I mean what
can I say about Raiders it has its
parents it
yeah it's it's unbelievable you people
don't realize back then and earlier that
you could buy a ticket and just not
leave the theater or under maybe maybe
was written maybe that changed after
Star Wars probably you know although
technically Raiders comes after that
yeah but what I mean is that because
before Star Wars I think people could
just stay in the theater all day and but
anyway we're off on a real tangent what
do you collect uh collects not a big
collector of things I think I do love
some movie memorabilia friend of mine
got me a one of the from alien the
original alien one of mother the ships
mothers like programmed disks so I have
that from the Nostromo that's in my
office
it's kind of I don't collect a whole lot
of stuff sure have you borrowed any
props or costumes from the set of these
fast and furious movies I mean mostly
our costumes tend to be muscle shirts
and things and things like that's and
I'd say no haven't really borrowed a lot
of that however some of the cars some of
the cars we have taking it for test
drives and you know just kind of fun I
have one of the cars from he was Furious
7
yeah I think it's the one it's the it
was Letty's like 1970 Plymouth Barracuda
so that was a nice radio did a very nice
thing and that kind of gave me that and
yeah so that's what is that in like the
garage it is right but it's funny
because everyone's like oh my gosh you
should drive that around all day
it is a stunt car it's got a I think
it's a four gallon engine and a special
like stunt roll like you drive it it is
so loud and the clutch is so like tricky
it's not really a Sunday kind of Cruiser
it's it's more of like a performance
stunt vehicle so tends to sit we take it
out occasionally some of my friends
combine they want to drive it we do when
we get back and they're like ooh that's
scary that's still awesome though yeah
yeah a lot of people don't realize that
the cars you see in the movies are not
the cars you want to own yeah a lot of
the times although some are for example
in Hobbes and Shaw the McLaren they were
so cool to us so when we decided to do
the movie we reached out we knew that
you know for Shaw let me back up in all
our films the cars kind of represent who
the characters are at their core level
like the cars are kind of like their
soul and I've always said it's like a
like a samurai film you know the swords
represent the soul of the samurai or a
cowboy movie your horse said something
about who that cowboy is so for ours you
know for our characters from you know
from every single character we picked
the cars kind of represent who they are
in a glance you can see it and know what
kind of style they are and kind of
person they are so with Shaw in this
film when we were picking the cars we
wanted something British for sure and
something sleek and something sports car
II so we went to McLaren like I had
talked to Jason about it I'm like if we
could pick any car I'm like we were
thinking McLaren he's like I love
McLaren so he went to McLaren and they
were amazing partners but to get them
onboard they loved the movie they loved
the idea but we had to like tell them
specifically what we're going to do with
the cars and that's always really fun
it's like and you have to lead them
through I mean turn by turn hit by hit
bullet by bullet just so they know
exactly what they're getting into
because what you'd hate to do is
have you a nice beautiful car or sign up
for a movie as a hero car and suddenly
it ends up a junker at the flood right
so we're like that's not going to happen
we're trying to represent that Shaw's
incredible driving skills and the
machine is amazing now the point I'm
trying to get to and sorry for the long
answer is that that car is so finely
made that we had to have the programmers
come out because it wouldn't allow our
stunt drivers to do the stunts that they
needed to do so they try to kick it into
a drift or kick it into spin and the car
would auto correct for it to keep the
driver safe it's that advanced so we had
to have somebody sit with our stunt
driver drive the car and as they tried
to do the stunt and wouldn't work the
guy would reprogram the chip so then it
would allow them to do it like they were
amazing partners that's a great car
right I was gonna say an amazing amount
of free publicity 100% yeah yeah big
global movie and the car looks so
awesome so awesome and Jason gets to
drive it he loves it it's great and also
you have a scene where the three of them
are in it together yes which I don't
know I guess it's physically possible
put a minute right they are in that car
I couldn't believe it when I saw it oh
my gosh we didn't the test that day we
had him we had the McLaren outside and
we were trying to put three people and
see how we'd fit them we put happy in
the middle and where was that guy seeing
them all just kind of get in there and
kind of crushed in there were like God
is gonna work this is a great great
thing um so jumping into I want to go
backwards do you remember what it was
that what was the big break for you in
terms of how you got either an agent or
how you got like noticed if you will
because a lot of people are trying to
write movies and get rake into the
industry but what was it that you did so
here's here's what happened with me and
here's the lesson I took from it and
it's a little bit of a longer story but
I'm gonna jump into it if that's okay
sure okay so I was working at the video
store like I said and I got a job as a
PA on a movie and it was flubber with
Robin Williams a long long time ago but
I'm just did I'm basically a glorified
like coffee runner you know and while I
had been working the video store I had
written a screenplay so I'm up in it was
a San Francisco we were shooting and I'm
doing my job and another PA walks by my
bag
his name's Wayne bill heimer he's worked
for Ireland I works for Apple and and he
sees this script sticking out and he
goes oh what are you reading I go oh no
that's mine he goes oh my god I got a
look at that you got it let me look at
that so I said okay so he takes it away
I reads it I come back at night and I go
hey you read the script he goes yeah
there you go would you think he's like
yeah I'm like uh heartbreak movie ends
go back to the video store
maybe it's six months later and the
phone rings I don't lock me out a video
can I help you
hey this is Chris yeah hey this is Wayne
remember me I was the p-n thing yeah
yeah he was listen I'm working for a
director now this guy named Vincent Ward
do you mind if I keep thinking about
that script do you mind if I show it to
him I said oh my god that'd be great I
hear nothing for four months right but
this is what happens so Vincent Ward
reads it likes it does not want to make
it but he gives it to his development
person a woman named Sarah Whistler who
reads it likes it does not want to make
it and gives it to a a woman named
Andrea McCall it was a story editor and
still is over at DreamWorks and cut to
me at the video store but I mean locking
in a video can I help you is this Chris
Morgan yeah it is hi my name is Andrea
McCall I work for DreamWorks on the
story editor just read your script can
you come in for a meeting today I'm like
oh my god so call my boss I'm leavin I'm
leavin closing down the store unless you
get here in five minutes like so he came
in very nice and I went I'm like I'm
gonna sell screen plated and I walk into
Andrea's office and she goes not buying
your script just seeing though really
must mean you not doing that we're doing
a movie called gladiator and my script
was like this big fifth century Welsh
siege movie she's like we already have
like a period and action thing that
we're doing but I really liked your
script I really liked your writing I
wanted to meet you so we talked for like
an hour at the end she said here's
here's an age like two agents and here's
like a lawyer give them a call let them
know that I am recommending you I just
really like your writing and I'd like to
see you get a start I've never worked
with them I've never done anything for
them so all of those people but
specifically you know Wayne and Andrea
reached out and gave me an entirely new
life right just out of the goodness of
their heart by the way that's not an
easy thing to do if you don't have an
agent or something like that there's a
little bit of like possible
like you saw my script and then some but
she was just kind and changed my life
and so that's a lesson that I always
remember it's like in this industry be
kind try to help try to help but what
are the take away so the take away is
one be cool because you can change
someone's life that's awesome and then
to be ready if I didn't have that script
sitting in that bag none of that would
have happened but cuz it was there
because I had taken the time to write
something on my own an opportunity came
by but that's the lesson and by the way
everyone's got those stories like you
talk to any writer they have that same
type of story it's kind of a crazy sort
of thing but that's mine
so what see from there did you sign with
those people I did and so and then what
my lawyer is the same lawyer from all
those years ago Jeff Frank oh yeah
so what so what was the first thing that
you got paid to do after getting so I
opted that script I was called siege
master I wrote it with the idea of Sean
Connery in mind and then later we
tailored it for Schwarzenegger I
remember that which was so fun
and then the first gig that I got the
first writing gig was actually SWAT the
movie SWAT I did a kind of like a
big-budget it's kind of like a fast like
ensemble giant action movie and I wrote
the script I came on after some other
writers and I just did it like a bigger
more fun type of version and they came
back they're like listen this is way too
expensive we're definitely not making
this and then they got David Ayer to
come on and they made the movie that
came out which was a great movie but off
of that my relationship with one of the
producers there I got hired to do a
movie called cellular which had that
dude that dude
as our villain and the cast in that
movie is pretty crazy like we got Chris
Evans Captain America we got Jason
Statham as our villain and we got Kim
Basinger bill Macy Jessica Biel's in it
like crazy crazy crazy movie and then
from that they did a this is the whole
Chris Morgan story I don't know why I'm
telling you this but no no we did on
that they did actually cuz yes people
want to know how the f does this
actually happen that's how that happened
so I do that movie and then
off of that movie from one of the people
that I worked with on SWAT they were now
sorry let me back that up
that's from cellular I should say I
heard that there was a it's not an open
writing call but it kind of was like a
little bit more of a not a cattle call
but a lot of writers that Universal was
looking to do a sequel to fast they were
going to a third Fast & Furious movie
but it was ten million dollars straight
to DVD that's what set in LA that's what
the that's what they were looking to do
and then I was just young and didn't
really know what I was doing and I kind
of came in and pitched okay what if they
bring back Dominic Toretto and someone
in Japan gets killed they're doing this
thing in Japan look at this these are
things called drifting look at this
video this is a dragon rundown amount
it's so cool Dom has to go he's got to
learn a new style of racing he's got to
figure out wrong side of the road and
how to drift to fit in to solve the
crime of figure out who killed the
person that he cares about and then at
the time they they're like listen us too
expensive we're not going to do it and
ultimately
I didn't get the job but too excited
they called up and they said listen that
drifting thing that's pretty crazy what
if we do this movie and we set it in
high school and that became Tokyo Drift
and then at the end you know as we're
getting ready to come out you know we
had the idea to do a tag with with Ben
and so Geoff Kirshenbaum who worked the
studio at the time went over to vans
reached out to him Ben thought about the
possibility and we're you know where it
could lead you know down the road and
signed on and we did the tag and movie
comes out and now people like the movie
it's a cult hit I mean you got some Kang
what's not to love in that movie but all
they were kind of like the press and
reviews and things were like yeah that's
good movie but oh my god they're gonna
bring back Diamond treto and they bring
back Brian O'Conner what's gonna happen
it let us survive to do fast-forward and
five and six and seven and eight and by
the way this is where the story all ties
together yeah see eventually put it so I
want to jump into Fast Five for a second
yeah because if I'm not mistaken and I
could be wrong about this you sort of
took from like there was like another
story like a bank job or something and
it all got melted into what we have or
am I wrong about that
uh I don't know if it's wrong I'll tell
you what the original conceit was that
that Brian and Mia the I remember
talking about this with with Jeff Kirsch
your mom and with Ben and studio but the
original idea was movie opens up and
somewhere south of the border and we see
two cars on the horizon and they're just
booking booking so fast and raising dust
and finally they pull over in this
little village and Brian and Mia get out
and they they keep looking back over the
horizon something's following them they
don't know what it is but they look
scared and then out of the other car Dom
gets out and pretty soon they do see the
dust of someone else coming and what you
realize is somebody is the law somebody
is after them someone actually very
similar to Butch and Sundance who
they're not scared of anything except
Joe the four is the man in the white hat
who ruined that I stopped coming after
them that's our Luke Hobbs that's Dwayne
Johnson so we knew that back then we're
like Dwayne is comin and it's the one
person they can't shake after all these
trying and me admits that you know she's
gonna have a baby soon they can't keep
runnin they have to solve it what's the
answer to that we need enough we need
enough money to disappear forever and
that's the high so it wasn't like we had
a different movie and kind of clued you
in something else that was the original
conceit we knew we were gonna go big
heist and that's what we did
yeah I Fast Five for me anyway I love
Fast Five I mean thank you yeah yeah
that's just a fantastic film it's fun it
ends on the right note the song is so
good everyone like your crew has
struggled so hard and it's the first
time we really kind of bring everybody
in together and just well that's almost
like it's really working that's also for
me and I think I could be wrong about
this but that's like the reset of the
franchise yeah you know we're like I
don't want to say people became
superheroes but people gained powers if
you will for sure and just a word about
that like you know what lets us do that
kind of stuff is that I'm a huge fan of
the original film like I'm not a giant
car guy I love cars for what they can do
in action sorts of thing
lateral thinking car stuff but if you
were to ask me like what engine is in
that car and how much horsepower I
haven't no I don't I have no clue I I
actually go to literally the best car
people on the planet Dennis McCarthy who
works over at Universal who knows
everything but what I invested in in the
original film was those characters their
bond their relationship they're not all
related they are family even though
they're the bad guys they stand for
something good and something greater
they all have this moral code so much so
that Paul Walker's character who's a cop
who should bust them knows he should
bust them they're dirty he actually
understands them and thinks they stand
for something bigger than the law that
they've been breaking that has always
stuck with me I think that's what people
love about the franchise you know that
the most important thing to them is the
love of the people around them so what's
great about that is that that's a real
human thing and I think everybody kind
of likes and it grounds our bigger
action in a way that lets us kind of get
away with more physically sure
physics-defying sorts of things also
like genre skips like the fact that
we're able to do in five because we know
the characters like the characters and
invested in them and we can switch into
a heist movie and that's just one of the
hurdles and challenges that they get to
overcome and in Hobbes and Shaw we get
to do that again we get to go into a
little bit of a superhero we get a
little bit of future military tech
little SciTech you know and as long as
you're invested in the characters you
make the leap and you know I have this
rule also on kind of on what set pieces
we can allow and which ones we want my
dad was a science teacher and I love
physics I love science I never want to
break the rules of physics but I don't
mind bending them at all like that
actually is fun so the rule is was to
the rule is is it cool
is it cool so that when you see it
you're like that's awesome okay that's
one you have to have that check mark but
the other check mark is when you're
watching it do we do things that break
physics so badly that it pops you out of
the movie right that you're like now I
can't enjoy it anymore I'm not
about the characters because because
it's so clearly in defiance of the real
world that I'm out we will go up to that
line but if it goes past that we will
pull it out and we've gotten close right
like so for example it's actually an
incredible set piece and six
the Antonov jet right this is the best
example the cars are trying to bring it
out of the skies is trying to take off
down the runway do the physics on it the
runway has to be something like 26 miles
long in order to to have that at that
airspeed and with those cars and that
long of a set piece but I would ask you
like when you're watching the movie did
that pull you out or were you invested
in Han and Giselle and Dom and all those
guys and I think the answer is you were
so that kind of set piece is awesome for
us that's the sweet spot sure um who
goes to space sooner The Fast and
Furious franchise were Mission
Impossible well okay let me ask you this
didn't they do a halo jump it's does
that count his space or not to go
farther I think you need the halo jump
is on the on the the threshold yeah but
it's not space hmm then I'm gonna say
cuz I asked Cruz and McQuarrie this yeah
I say
they said that if they could figure out
a story reason yeah also I think
ultimately it's insurance costs because
you know cruise would actually want to
go to space 100% and so then it's like
how do you insure Tom Cruise to go to
space I mean no BS it's like not yeah
not the Vomit Comet
not under the kc-135 but actual space
and so ultimately it's the insurance way
for him to do it
see I think that's the thing that gives
us the edge right there cuz I don't know
if we'd actually go into space space
like maybe we would fake it a little bit
but I I would say this their answer is
100% ride is is I would go I would take
the fast crew anywhere anywhere any
Chandra any place provided that the the
character reason grounds it and the
story necessitates it to the point where
the audience it's irresistible they have
to go there they sure have to well cuz
listen I think jason has a twin brother
that had recently fought a giant shark
he did
so I'm just curious also about going
under the water you know a Meg team-up I
mean there's listen little underwater
outer space
they've been pitched right I pitched it
hastily to Jason and on the set every
day I'd come in with an ear leg okay so
here's what happens with the maze right
um I actually had a blast with the Mack
me too it's so fun Jason yeah I did a
great job in that Jason so what we call
a fun guide watch for sure okay so I
want to ask you a few other things too
what I mean there's been talk about a
female spinoff yeah of The Fast and
Furious franchise is that something
that's currently being worked on I'm
gonna let the studio give the official
answer for that but as a general kind of
overarching answer we've we've been
looking to expand the fast world for a
while and we've taken our time and taken
our care with it and you know after we
saw fast ate that scene of them in the
prison of Dewayne and Jason and just
their banter back and forth and Dwayne's
just kind of swagger II and you know
throwing Barb's and Jason's returning
them we knew that that might be the
perfect first step to widen the universe
and kind of the rule of fast is
everything that happens in the fast
universe has ramifications to everything
else fast to me is a giant spiderweb
where everything kind of interconnects
and sometimes it'll go away but it
always comes back and I would say with
Hobbes and Shaw hopefully the audience
responds to it opens up I mean
technically today but tomorrow and you
know we've been talking a lot with
studio about other sorts of things
exactly like that I don't know if David
officially or not that ye but yes we are
we're definitely well there's there's a
lot of characters 100% you know and I
mean amazing characters I there's a lot
of young empowered tough cool lateral
thinking action II awesome characters
and in a way that we haven't seen you
know I think I think I think that
project will be incredible I think it
would be a highlight of the fashion
universe one of the things listen the
action in Hobbs in Shaw is you know
David did a great job but for me my
favorite parts are all the scenes of
Dwayne and Jason and Saul
each other yeah because it there's so
many of them and they're all so fun
yeah and they're just ripping each other
that scene behind you was the first day
they were together on set right there we
had seen first time that they come in
there you know and just they went for it
they were for it yeah that's all great
stuff so my thing is that what was it
like you know those scenes putting them
together it's great I you know I've had
experience with that on several movies
now and the process is always that so
I'll write the screenplay
so I'll write a full version of it and
then I'll pitch it to the guys so they
know what it is and they'll be thinking
about things and then we'll either get
together beforehand and tweak you know
kind of the way that we do it is it's
super collaborative and it's always best
idea wins it's actually the most fun
thing for me about about the film is
that you really do have this kind of
family that is looking to fight for the
audience that's what they want to do
they want to make sure that when
audience leaves they feel like it was
worth their money and they're you know
excited to have seen the movie so I'll
write the script we'll talk about it
then we'll come to set and whatever
version the script is in at that point
have if we have rewritten it to kind of
match it doesn't matter on the day we
just keep it open so we have that
blueprint the guys will do it but then
things will come up like Dwayne will
have something he wants to sneak in and
hit Jason with Jason will have something
he wants to sneak in they'll both come
to me to look for other stuff to write
and kind of hit each other with well
just have fun it's great so that was
really fun because we had the original
dialogue and then that exactly happened
where both of the guys are like would be
full what about this what about this so
their lines of I think it's specifically
it's like I figured it out it's you know
your voice your voice it's like dragging
my balls crossed out of glass or you
know it's your big stupid face you know
that was stuff that we came up with
sitting on right there sitting on that
set it's just so fun it's all I'm sure
you've sat in theaters watching I mean
people are just laughing yeah it's great
stuff there you know um so I know you're
you're touching like you're working on
other things I looked on the always
accurate IMDB and it's like comically
wrong or you know stuff in various what
what exactly is coming up for you like
what
what else are you working on right now
uh working on a bunch of stuff we have a
bunch of projects that we're kind of
getting up and going but right now it is
it's this it is waiting on a response
and saying whatever kind of comes next
we have some other projects that we love
there's one called
crime of the century with Dan
Trachtenberg that's been in I've heard
about that one it's so good right so
good so that's something we're looking
to kind of get up and going next and we
have a kind of a slate of other films
ranging from very modest you know
modestly budgeted to big and also
television so I have a new TV deal over
it over at Sony that we're looking to
kind of do things over there and then
frankly fast like how do we you know if
the universe is accepted and people like
it expanding there's so many other
stories I'd love to tell like the fact
that we got to do is spin off with two
characters is so great because you get
to dig a little deeper on who they are
where they come from
what their fears are I would love to be
able to do that with some other
characters in the fast universe that'd
be so fun
you have obviously over your career
written the number scripts mm-hmm I'm
assuming there's a number of them that
have never been made for sure what is
the script or two scripts that you've
written that you feel are still like man
I wish we can get these off the ground
I the one that I mentioned the first one
siege master is one it's so close to my
heart it's just a big period rollicking
action movie that's it's really really
fun I did a feathered fish of a script a
long time ago but I still love it it was
a Bermuda Triangle script but it was
more horror but it was a giant budget
horror there's no way anyone could ever
possibly make it it's just too expensive
to support its own weight but I love
that as well I really loved it was it
what it was the title on it it's really
creative it was Bermuda try yeah when
you're saying expensive are you talking
like over 100 million oh yeah way oh
really yeah
no way it was so dumb like it was one of
those things that I wrote just because I
was so obsessed and passionate about it
and I didn't have my producer hat in
that stage of my career
I literally just wrote for like I think
the audience would love this and I
believe they would have loved it but no
studio could make it because there's
just not going to be enough people
willing to come see a movie that is that
dark at that budget you just can't I got
to tell you one of the other ones I
would love to get going that I did not
write but man i I'm so passionate about
was Conan Conan we had a map legend -
Conan or yeah we'd be well basically it
would be a sequel - I love Conan the
Barbarian I mean I love the Robert E
Howard books and stories I really love
the 81 movie I love I'm obsessed with it
like people will be like ads you know
it's big dumb Conan it's not it's a
smart script a smart story it's
elegantly made like it's a it's actually
a great movie we did a sequel that was
30 years later and it was kind of
Unforgiven that the idea is you know
what if what if Conan wasn't strong
anymore he's kind of reaching the end of
his life and this big kind of nasty
event happens that he's got to get
called into action but he can't do what
he used to do can't fight his way
through it what do you do do you have
value when you're older do you have a
different way of doing things it was it
was awesome love it but yeah we'll see
I've heard about this project was it the
fact that was it just like money was it
just I think it's a lot of things it's
yet money rights it's expensive
well uni has they had the rights and
there's a hole yeah it's a whole kind of
it's the business side of the business
right we should have to respect and and
there's a time clock on everything and
you know having said that though it's
one of those projects it'll be a
lifetime sort of quest for me who knows
what where it goes and what they do with
it but man I would love
- I'd love to kind of get a shot at that
I wonder if after the new Terminator
depending on you know Arnold's role and
you know what I mean person you know I
just don't I also wonder like because it
would obviously be Arnold mhm and it's a
lead role big lead role right and so the
question then becomes is he can he do
what he's you know what I mean it's
literally all it's asking and we had our
you know the script specifically address
that exactly those things all those
questions like because when you're
sitting in the audience you look and he
now he's an older guy and can you do
those things and you know don't you want
to get him up to eventually kind of do
something like that and is that a great
audience chair moment all those all
those great sorts of matters I
completely get it I'm gonna stop there
and just say that thank you so much for
coming in and you and I enjoyed the deep
dive into how you actually made it in
Hollywood you know what I mean
and listen Hobbs and Shaw is a blast I
hope everyone goes to see it especially
in IMAX it's playing in imax for at
least a week and no because it's I love
IMAX and it's anyway if you like fast I
think you'll I think you'll enjoy the
movie I think it's so there's really fun
time Dwayne's at his best and so jason
vanessa kirby is incredible idris elba
come on yeah we also we also haven't
even talked about if there were any
surprises in the movie that there are
surprises in the movie there are several
right all right a lot yeah and we've
struggled very hard to kind of keep
secret and we'll see we'll see what
happens after this weekend but it's so
fun
well it'll be out by tomorrow but like I
mean terms of the all the surprises but
it's amazing you made it this far yes
thank you
you know anyone thank you so much for
coming in thank you and on that note
everyone go check out Hobbs and JA